i went skiing recently with my friend  we're sitting on the ski lift i was like  why don't you see more black people  skiing why is that my friend has no idea  but he's gonna you know half-ass his way  through it because he don't want to see  him dumb so he's like ah you know  they don't grow up with it  like well i'm from louisiana i'm here  well  skis very expensive ah right right right  yeah yeah you know i've never seen a  black guy with anything expensive on  their feet  just say you don't know it's all right  you sound way worse that's why black  people are smarter white people we do  crazy stuff we swim with sharks we go  bungee jumping cliff diving ask a black  guy why do they do that again i don't  know it's white people [ __ ]  that's a good answer  they don't sit around going well you  know europe